here we go okay I know I shouldn't have
done it
oh yeah everyone knows you can trust
them they said they won't tell I know
but what if anyone gets scared and calls
the cops she don't know what can happen
[Music]
these people won't have to worry about
any of this once we're in [__] portal Oh
box
what's the Lilith
um okay I've got to be careful because I
was playing sorry I was playing a game I
think it was on the Resident Evil and
some people were saying I was giving the
motion sickness so they keep waving the
camera around to hit that party I'm
sorry it's just the way that I play okay
there's a party and so oh this is cute
Finn the great philosopher leader of the
group of the group knows everything
about weed yeah I'm not a fan of Finn
he turned our little brother oh this is
cool
turned our little brother to the dark
side
well not really but he got my throwing
knives and stuff that's dangerous I
don't want my little brother doing that
oh yes Mira the campfire
depression night everyone shed their
wife's memory all right and then I went
with Daniel
cool no I like the little bear
okay let's go them up to the party hey
killing has hit hate his kiss
yes I'm online and yes I do you read for
the chat from time to time
hey it's lucky here he is
here's the guy that I don't like so much
that's Pete's room have a seat
have a beer - our last night together
and - your next adventure
so what are you gonna do next figure out
what I'm gonna do me and Daniel yeah
when I got out of jail I had nobody but
me my brothers were still in the joint
they still are I stayed with from nobody
could find me then I just said [__] you
took off that was it man no more family
just me always trying to find a new
daddy or new bros stupid I knew I had to
well you found new roots in him start
over all for myself
Jesse you're doing you starting all over
and now you've just got to take the next
step to build a something for you and
Daniel right oh it's way with words
I have no clue what I want to do anymore
I'm just like what's the point we're
screwed
that's why you have to keep on keepin on
nobody said it was easy but you guys are
bad [__] yeah it's gonna be all
right laddie you have enough cash I
doubt it but we'll see
hey it's [__] after all this you
deserve seriously how are you two gonna
get to Mexico
eh I walk just hear me out man there's
only one way out of this listen we got
this Shawn
Daniel can open that safe with his eyes
closed no we're not using Daniel to
steal a bunch of money probably wasted
like every night you guys can get to
play the Lobos in style with nest egg
think he wants to use our little brother
to watch deal I'm not homeless anymore
right oh so negative then let's do this
I wouldn't let you in on this if I had
any doubt
no I'm not doing it I don't care I'm not
doing it I can't finish no way too
dangerous for Daniel nah Daniel he's the
dangerous one nobody can even touch him
you know I said no I bet you're pissed
at us because he didn't get paid I would
be too I'm so sorry
okay he's such a good friend
no stress man I respect your decision
just wanted to help you makes me sad
gonna miss you Shaun true thanks Finn
same here
I'm glad you and Daniel have each other
you too special
you got powers don't take [__] from
anybody a blur again dawn get back to
your party I'm stone cool
and rather work my ass off
yeah really getting kicked out with this
place no I'm so sorry killing hsx if I
didn't requite your email I get ready
overwhelmed with them sometimes but I'm
guessing I probably read it and it
probably made me extremely happy
remember sorry but thank you I
appreciate it
Oh like Xbox think there's more than
water in this can he's 40 oh we can
Cassidy's been busting my balls about
tattoos
[Music]
looks like she meant no no we're gonna
get tattoos and is hey guys what's up oh
yeah shyness in the house grab a broom
smoke a ball
I'm good [__] lightweight that's what
you get for keeping all the coffee to
yourself messin with you man
Hey Dude what's up with Jenks posters
hey I saw the James posters by your tent
are you still looking for him
what were you looking over there for so
this is being nosy didn't mean to pry
it's fine yeah I still carry these
around drop them around when I can you
know just okay but no move so far I'm
sorry about that we hear rumors about
this place never think it was their life
you chose though yeah we'll meet again
you know badass [__] I hope you
do
I'm so pissed we have to bail tomorrow
[__] [__] there I can't figure this
guy hates me love spin kicks you out
crazy [__] doesn't matter now we're gone
no more drama
I wouldn't race on this job anything I
can hook you up with another farm really
that would be [__] if you can no
words okay so you've got another option
to make money that's good that's good
so what's the next stop for you two
travelers
I want to go north Ingrid wants to go
south to both [__] that I want to see
Canada she go to takes ass at least you
have a choice still going down Mexico
little wave it is one way won't mind
being in that heat Bell this is summary
compared to de treat summer
okay I'm done more beer and weed for you
you leave it lightweight we party for
you Sean talk later
can I still not talk to them yet oh I
can do it to Cassidy hey everything okay
Diaz my favorite straight-a student I'm
gonna leave you guys alone
no don't I can go if I'm interrupting
don't worry we're done I think I need
some alone time anyway
okay cheer up sister Oh it's cuz they're
arguing about which way which way to go
hurry about that secret girl talk
I'm so bummed you guys are leaving no
[__]
are you still going to Mexico yeah these
we have to try it's cool you have a gold
I can't wait to get the [__] out of here
but they want more cash then san likes
to get his week on why don't you come
with us is that are you serious yeah why
no she was she was sweet Shawn I'm not
cut out for that lakhs I can't stay in
the same place I need to move see places
they have and the last thing Daniel
wants is me bumming around and keep -
whoa down
[__] that [__] yes the time even if it's
our last night here we'll meet again
Shawn one thing I learned traveling is
how small the world is we already met
twice well not more even if we don't
yeah maybe
hey the best way to remember somebody is
no tattoo ready wait are you serious
goddamn right
this is like your initiation ritual
don't be scared
Cassie's here yeah let's do it
yes what's your favorite game yeah I'm
not sure I'm joking don't do it on your
own do it
stir it somewhere no one's gonna see why
is he gonna do it so what do you want
your uncut or something
should we ask for a surprise or should
we get a wolf I mean what's a cool
because the wolf pack thing right no way
today I'm gonna let you guys decide this
one because wolves make sense with the
storyline of the game and she could do
anything everybody asked her to surprise
me what do you guys think
handyman things surprise oh god I hope
it's not something already embarrass me
if I say surprise
anyone else anyone else okay if no one
flies in five seconds I'm gonna go with
surprises handyman said but Cass is
drunk could never get attached if I saw
one who's drunk she's not drunk is she
she's okay
okay we've got one for surprise
two for wolf yeah this is my first run
yeah she'll win gaming okay now we've
got two per wolf maybe she too wants a
PP wolf forgot to even one okay I go for
your Freddie not to cringe okay boy you
won't be disappointed here's to your
first tattoo Jean vias all right put
your arm over here you okay yeah yeah
hey don't know sweetie here but it
[__] hurts
that much until the end of the school
word dinner you won't feel the pain
eventually better mmm it's your name on
the butt chicken soup rice boy you're
right
at least I'm sure you'll never forget me
now I don't remember [__] just smooth it
Shawn you know it as much as I do who
knows what's coming for you a month from
now you can meet a sugar mommy or get
hired on a cruise ship to Egypt or
whatever and before you know it we'll be
a tiny memory all you need to do to
sterilizes use alcohol which they do
have I mean I don't know if yes spirits
but will you get a new tattoo to
remember me yes from that day at the
market I knew there was something in you
oh thanks it's the same for me
and hope that we meet again and we did
you know don't believe in fate but
sometimes laugh sure does look a lot
like it
yeah I'm done no that was waiting oh my
good this will keep it warm for the net
you'll need the bad healing balm when
you can
what if we get lying what I have to tied
to something like now come with me shall
we
he's a little wolf that was cool
hope I don't even want to climb I
actually kind of get
hey Daniel
we're gonna go to the lake
okay I'll just be here come get me when
you want to go to sleep
yeah okay good I'm glad he said that
because I'm gonna go to that I'm gonna
go to the lake yeah sorry that makes
your emotions what is that doing this
wait no wrong way
so don't make her wait at the lake dude
[Music]
the surprise tattoo was way worse what
was it Maria can you tell me what it is
can you tell me what the surprise
thought she was I think we don't want to
know in the chat don't we I definitely
do
oh yeah we're not supposed to swim after
getting a tattoo
should have done this before
just keep on Rama I mean what are you
waiting for
oh [__] this
it's freezing it's all in your head just
don't think about it sure don't think go
on okay Barney has one night I think
yeah yeah get over it
hurry up there you go bring it home
hey you gotta take it all on no cheating
chasity do not even you are so adorable
yeah I know not bad yes didn't think
you'd actually do it my body just had to
get used to it not that cold that's
because I had to pee ha so what are you
gonna do about Finn
you know his plan it's a really stupid
idea way too dangerous especially for
gaming I know Finn acts like this is no
big deal
it just feels bad plus I don't want you
guys to get in any more trouble yeah
tell that to Danny he's gonna be pissed
he's your brother they'll listen to you
Finn wants to take care of us but but he
doesn't always see other people it's all
about him I've noticed feel bad for you
in stream Hillier age for a while for
sure
he likes you what do you mean come on
heartbreaker you know everybody likes
you I feel guilty
I'm not into dating why would I say that
no I like you too
Oh Shawn that's sweet I'm fighting over
to you bust out this line whenever you
go skinny dipping first time I swear you
sure
I'm not that much of a player as you can
tell hmm I don't know I'm both already
naked hey that's your fault
so do you wanna kiss me
yes yeah if that's cool this is like
friends yeah I get really awkward
watching scenes like this
now the wetness on their faces look so
good it's all like dappled and stuff
damn song you really are cold shut up
stop looking
playing this game just once when you go
camping
Oh hold on this egg okay
it's been worse I'm just checking to see
how clean it is
if you want to
do you have protection I think she has
condoms right yeah I do get in bro bro
sorry for the mess Porter's rejected my
application again
are you cool
totally I'm just nervous
kind of um we waited too now no [__]
you're kind of a so playing with you
yeah
[Music]
now we're all cozy right yeah hey listen
I I think you should know that
I know
dan yeah but get miss cherry pops
but everything
all of her cool tats
is that a fox she's got a fox that do
under a boob I like it
oh wait where has my brother just he go
to bed oh I feel bad no I told him to go
I guess
hey what's that
nothing I just
he's just sad
talk to me sorry I am
sorry it sucked Sean this is your first
time I won't give you a bad review
online promise that's sweet but you
don't have to be like that
hey I mean it Sean just take it easy
you'll have time to practice okay
okay we need some fresh air let's get
dressed
until we [__] again
cool
Shawn it's all good okay
hey what's happening wait did you guys
just have sex yeah yep I can't find him
well you didn't say anybody out there
hey we'd better go now if you're staying
always with him just tell Finn I want to
talk
thanks much later Shawn hold up wait a
sec why we have to stop him
let's figure out a plan first we don't
have time for that [__] I can't believe
that we told him no and he freaking did
it anyway - I didn't - it's all Jewish
trucks screw Finn not in the same way as
anyway this is so messed up yeah
[__] get mad later got [__] to do
if something happens [__] me okay
I'm back thanks for coming with me
Cassidy don't thank me
Weaver gone what ten minutes twenty she
we don't want Big Joe to see us somebody
build the lock
of course you probably got a checker
gone
what Chuck is missing
see those tracks are headed out [__]
at least they didn't wake Big Joe up but
if we do he'll kill us
Shawn so let's not advertise the lights
no noise I'll check the car you do the
truck oh my god okay
this truck we're gonna do with it
I gotta you
okay
figures check the other door hands
check the car all doors locked of course
keep looking around I'm gonna check on
the truck
one door left to check
yes check it out
so all the doors are locked but just get
it get into one car and I think I can
get that truck started she's shaking me
my dad
was a mechanic he won't show me how to
hotwire his tow truck just in case
Chaldeans you're full of surprises
plus we could mess with all the other
cars so Big Joe can't follow us love
what do you think we can find some
things here to blush it up but we can't
make a sound okay
get the hood open
get this window
I hope we're not like being tired right
now focus you have to get into that
truck
anything around here or something might
be something in a junk
these bunch of pigs sure don't care
about this place
nope
just gotta get in that truck and start
her up oh I don't know how
nothing in there I can open up the rear
window getting through here yeah but I
need to I need to do something to the
other cars first anyway
geez come on give me something
okay I think now we get to go over by
locking here
thanks for stopping by jazz sake glad
you enjoyed the stream oh it's rat
poison that's why there's no critters
around here
nice
what am I gonna do with that
nothing over you
maybe you can use that to pick a lock or
something I don't want to smash our way
in because this is stupid
it's in the box
what's in the box
oh is that key hell yeah
maybe this fits in one of the cars
cool
[__] up the other car
how do we talk it over / ah
there she was
thank you for the follow cyan ish
so they did it gonna follow us now oh
cool okay now hopefully these keys are
work come on
what if the keys go to them
there's not a key to today McDaniel rear
windows that
score
why don't I have keys
almost
great cannot do that does it I was
looking at chat sorry
hey wolf 733 one good evening from the
UK
we punish it all the tire that's fine
creep it out here
anything news following this junk
yeah I am locked the door I'm just doing
the tires you know just making like what
ruefully sure that they are not gonna
follow us
even though I think I have count the
engine or something
Oh
score
oh my gosh
hammer
I don't quite know what I need that for
though should we take their cartridges
so they don't have okay don't think I
can use that
ya know
hey villa was it no this is definitely
not some old resin evil Saanich yeah
thank you
cute same for me
okay well we have a lot of stuff now I
don't know if you had to use a lot yeah
what what Big Joe we're cool
bet he's asleep hop in
I love driving all junkies
okay let's do this take it easy Sean
that's loud dry
this ain't your first car tech shop
did it wake him up
[Music]
[__]
I just want to get this over with
don't say that things can't go wrong for
the matter we've had this is basic karma
I want this to continue
we should go they might not even be
inside you
I mean they were way ahead of us
Vinnie's attitude has he done this
before
now because Finn thinks day he was his
golden ticket
he just gets Brady otter catch you
destroy
I don't want him to use our little
brother like this finish so annoying
there's anything over here that we hear
news
this is the truck they took
gosh I'll be fine together
how what smell gonna do if he catches
them fiends are smart
but what if we get cold you never trust
Finnish
I wouldn't Hannah is gonna go ballistic
just you good at least Mara won't know
anyone's coming
ah I have a bad feeling about the season
I big [__] you scared the [__] out good
you're gonna wait maril thing no [__]
way
come on Shawn are you kidding me how
could you do that thing he's a [__]
kid he's nine years old he asked me for
it
I didn't force him man but you knitted
he's too young to make that kind of
decision
boxing he's an old soul he knows what's
up
hold on please you're standing near a
boatload of cash we can do this in five
minutes in and out and then you're off
to Mexico you won't care about me ever
again we got this man trust me no he's a
log won't even know wanna help Shawn get
out of here
[Music]
I know I'm saying I'm not letting him do
it no we're not doing it we're not doing
it they said no [__] way Sean please
what's done why should I come that's
dope now I'm sick of all this for weeks
you just ain't no one's hurt it's all
your fault I could do what I want crazy
the [__] are you doing here
[__]
don't move don't shook the [__] how many
are you just us it's just us
alright move your asses over there
now Merrill uh boss I know this looks
bad I just need to do the best don't
want to hear any more your [__]
so what was your big [__] plan
exactly
work here for a time and then break into
my safe
who was the [__] mastermind
I gave you Punk's worked with nobody
would a place to crash for free shut up
this is how you were pay me stealing
from me no no it's not about you
I thought you were different smart but
you're a real dumbass for getting a kid
involved and you're teaching them how to
steal the year nice but now you all
really [__] up I can't just let this
slide I can't you're young but you can
learn from mistakes that doesn't mean
your lessons gonna be easy or painless
okay on your knees hands on your head
don't do this don't come on sir we we
could talk I'm serious
on your knees we tried to stop this
I don't think he's in the discussing
mood right now
I think we just have to do what he says
he's not he's not talking to us we're on
our knees okay Merrill no just do it
don't break my balls now kid
just get on your damn knees yeah now he
can't do this
it's like oh so annoying trying to get a
kid did it help him no it's not like I
want to do this the people I deal with
worse
but if you rip me off you rip them off
oh crap
then I
I have a family to look after too
I got to protect them first
atchoo
I'll go
I don't know
I mean I don't like Finn but this is but
I also don't want to teach him that he
should use his powers but he needs his
powers for good and this is goodbye but
he shouldn't have been using his powers
I know game don't tell me how the game
has popped up behind my head telling me
how to select a choice I know how to
select a choice it's just a hard choice
to make because I think I'm gonna have
to use Daniels power I don't want him to
think that it's a good way oh I don't
know what do you guys think we were your
thoughts on this situation I'm just
waiting for the light to catch up I
think I'm gonna have to ask him to use
his power cuz
I don't really care about Finn by doing
what's gonna happen after that like I
don't know if he's gonna kill us all
after that or maybe Cassidy I don't want
that yeah sionis is like don't ask me
I'd run
caution is would be ready kill him off I
mean it seems like it I know he's his
favorite but he seems pretty pretty
angry guys oh deny
hide behind the keyboard and run from
your choices yeah
oh I don't know maybe it's a trap oh
[Music]
sure just do nothing
what other guys not gonna kill anyone
that's true what if he's not gonna kill
anyone
oh maybe he won't kill anyone okay fine
I'll do nothing
maril just listen please
boss I got greedy stupid I'll make it up
I know
Oh
[Music]
oh my god I thought that wouldn't
actually happen
Oh No
[Music]
what the [__]
he's got a piece of glass in his eye
what
No
oh so annoyed you can be a pirate now I
mean I didn't really like Finn anyway
but ah
does this mean Cassidy's dead to you is
like oh my god I'm actually very
stressed right now oh um I made coffee
for the others ups drinking last cup
only for EMAP said did that a you hit
the bull's eye whilst knife-throwing a
yo he tried to be understanding when
Daniel mentioned Karen Karen Karen you
asked Daniel why he doesn't wear his
watch yeah of course why wouldn't I you
intervened when Big Joe sucked Cassidy
yeah white knight you're trimming was
average what average I want to trim well
you helped Daniel clean the dishes good
brother you were sober at the campfire
most people got wasted
you went to see with Daniel yeah most
Eva did that yeah cuz he was getting all
sad and lonely and you came forward when
Daniel hip Big Joe yeah of course and
you were the first you were out well you
were out for the heist you were in for
the heist you eventually convinced a
part and the heist you oh yeah yeah you
and I wonder how you were eventually
convinced maybe that's like at the end
if you choose to do it you and Finn
remain friends you want Finn kissed
damn oh damn you think attached to you
you chose to get a wolf tattoo that's
what most people did you went to the
lake with Cassidy Cassidy didn't get
angry at you I guess because I didn't go
with Finn's idea
you kissed Cassidy you went into custody
ten Oh
yeah we sold a vehicle without a
lighting Big Joe whoa only 27 that 7%
did that maybe maybe you could then
smash into the car if you hadn't found
the keys you came in after Finn Antonio
broke into my house oh you could have
alerted Merril I wonder how something
smells house without being noticed maybe
there was a different entrance then into
the house you did nothing in Finn was
killed eight percent no oh cool you
could have shot Meryl well that's
different I wonder how you get that oh
there's a way that you could do nothing
and Finn wasn't killed I wonder how you
do that Cassidy was injured okay guys
she's not dead there was a gun in the
safe the hell I don't see that
now I wouldn't have want to kiss Finn
that egotistical he doesn't deserve
these lips oh the small Daniel waited
for you to come in the morning
Daniel had your help doing the dishes
and you refused to help with the water
tanks rude no he did though didn't he I
just didn't take his help I don't think
Daniel talked to with sure of us anger
that's nice Daniel staged put foot
lashed out after finding Finn was shot
dead and done your last night Sean
[Music]
Daniel disobeyed use his power and got
injured apparently he lashes out in all
of them then yeah at least he's not
injured I guess all of those endings
seemed pretty bad to me it's not good
this is it son
you're toast
and of the road your toast
no way out this time
we got a lot of rooms you know for
copper
you're alone
see dreaming
no I am a roast I have noticed
okay well honestly that's a good law of
my mental energy and I'm gonna call the
stream right here so thanks so much for
being with me wait what day is it
if we can figure out the day
I wonder okay so next Friday its next
Friday right when I wait let me yeah
is it next Friday that most evil comes
out I think it is the third April the
third yes yes is in that case then I'm
gonna have to do a live she won't Friday
I I was just like do I have anything
planned no of course not
we're all on lockdown no one's going out
of the house that's doing anything so
yeah
twenty-sixth much oh that's what the
date is today thank you very much I'm
around a bit but yeah I will see you
next Friday then if I tell you what
follow me on Twitter or on discord and
you'll know whether I decide to play any
more of this beforehand
that's my Twitter next Friday
yeah not tomorrow not this spider next
Friday not the next fire to come in no
but yeah I will play present evil and
damn I'm at sea ha I'm excited but I'm
also really scared because the demo the
demo was so difficult wait oh damn I'm
so blown out the demo was so difficult
and now I'm just like I'm gonna find it
so hard cuz I've set up my game on I I
might try playing with a mouse and
keyboard because someone someone
suggested that I I think I'm better with
a controller but I have been playing a
lot more PC games recently so we shall
see but you know me it's all about the
entertainment here it's not about the
amazing gene it was then maybe you
should go elsewhere but yeah so I'll
definitely see you oh yeah I've just put
my twist there I definitely see you guys
on Friday but if I decide to do another
livestream on Wednesday or Thursday I
will let you know probably through
Twitter or as usual on my disk or as
well
and I will say just pin the discord in
each other I will say it's so weird
because since we've been on lockdown you
think that you'd have more time to do
things but when you're working from home
and some land Vic just said at the
beginning of the stream you you're
fighting with a lot of different things
like you set up your internet connection
and it actually for me anyway I find
that I'm working longer hours because
I'm trying to kind of catch up with all
the time that I'm losing with all of
that so I feel it's so weird I thought
I'd have more time to do live streams or
talk to you guys more about that but I
think I'm actually doing it less so I
want to I guess I don't have to
apologize but I just want that you know
what's going on if you know I'm not
normally am that's probably why I'm not
in discord as much as I usually am
because I'm probably just trying to work
alongside having there's way more
meetings now as well I don't know if
anyone else having that in their job but
meetings happen a lot more often because
you can't see people so you end up
talking to people all day and yeah I
don't I'm just just let you know you can
go into this court and I will be in
there every now and then but I haven't
been in there very very much recently oh
thank you so much for your donation
master pin it's much appreciated that
was 43 minutes ago I'm very sorry that I
only just noticed it now Wow
but if you're still here thank you
thanks so much that means that means an
awful lot yeah it does mean a lot I have
been looking into getting a new webcam
as well to up the quality of the streams
but unfortunately
unfortunately all the webcams are gone I
can't find webcams anywhere like not
decent ones anyway
it's so hard I guess cause everyone's
working from home so if I was doing
conference calls and everyone needs a
webcam right so when I find a webcam I
will buy a webcam and that'll be crown'd
anyway enough rambling from me and seem
it's pretty high air stream so that's
for sure thanks all Milanovic many are
working on yeah like I see I saw I put
on Instagram the other day just a little
post just saying like don't worry if
you're not being productive see this
time because I see a lot of other posts
which they mean well I do understand but
they're just kind of saying like things
to do during this time and you can be so
creative and so productive but and then
I know some people are feeling guilty
because they're like oh I'm really not
being productive at all and then to me
it makes complete sense because you're
trying to work from home getting used to
new environments I mean it's your
environment but you know you're you're
basically working and living in the same
place you know and not only that it's
crazy times
you're probably worrying a lot and
that's totally understandable and you
should let yourself feel that way if you
don't I mean like if you want to spend
your time being productive doing
something crazy and whatever go do it if
that's what will make you happy great
but don't use it as a way to to distract
yourself from what you're actually
feeling all of the time because you need
to kind of register your mood and know
what you might need even if that is like
crying or something like that or phoning
someone that you
care about so yeah just wanted to say
that anyway
[Music]
yeah I know you guys are all being safe
so just keep doing that so you can do
just be safe check on on the people that
you love and be mindful we'll all get
through this it will be okay but I will
see you next week anyway so have a
lovely day or evening thanks for being
here with me I'm gonna say goodbye to
who I can see in the stream so oh yeah I
should win Gaming is playing Star Wars
and alone sounds cool
so goodbye yeah Xuan gaming goodbye Eric
du temple goodbye Alex see is observing
goodbye and some Milanovic goodbye mesh
heist goodbye ughter a man goodbye peace
teddy and goodbye anyone here Oh goodbye
master pin you are here thank you very
much for your donation really appreciate
it
goodbye sign ish and yeah goodbye to
anyone who might be watching but it's
not in the chat or perhaps I've missed
you because of maybe I need glasses I
don't know Oh goodbye Casper yeah you
can give my Chris Chris Christian Chris
is that like that but have a lovely day
or evening I will see you next week and
goodbye